on this wednesday night the brutal
bombing of a maternity and children's
hospital in ukraine
the victims and devastation and more
pleas for the west to intervene the
world war three is already began new
concerns about the old chernobyl plant
the potential consequences of that
facility losing its power supply the
changing face of the pandemic when
ontario will drop most of its mass
mandates and a new report on bc's
overdose crisis why thousands have died
and is there a solution plus a
century-old mystery solved you can see
her paintwork you can see the bolts
where the search for this famous sunken
ship finally ended
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
it is one of the darkest signs of the
inhumanity of russia's war on ukraine a
heavily pregnant woman among the injured
after a maternity and children's
hospital took a direct hit this massive
crater in the hospital courtyard shows
the impact of the strike
good evening and thanks for joining us
ukrainian authorities say 17 people have
been injured among the first to post
video of the devastation was ukraine's
president vladimir zelinski
it shows the hospital in ruins zielinski
tweeted people children are under the
wreckage
atrocity he wrote how much longer will
the world be an accomplice ignoring
terror close the sky right now stop the
killings you have power but you seem to
be losing humanity
this happened in mariopol a city that's
been under siege for days by russian
forces who have surrounded it and cut
off all supplies food and power
crystal commansing begins our coverage
tonight in a warning some of the images
in her story are graphic
workers were already calling the scene
apocalyptic before this strike now it's
a new level of terror expectant mothers
had to be ushered out of what should
have been a warm safe place as a
children's hospital and maternity unit
in mariupol became one of the latest
targets of russian aggression
the frantic video of the scene tries to
capture the scope of the devastation the
hospital where i were when i was a child
is bombed demetrio guerin is a ukrainian
politician from mariupol his parents are
still in the besieged city he's
frustrated saying there are many
examples of russian brutality with
ongoing and deadly strikes on civilians
and demands to know what else needs to
happen to force the world into action
the world war three it's already begun
and we have uh you have to understand
where is your line the maternity
hospital in ukraine is it enough is our
blood is red enough for you
red cross volunteers are trying to help
the vulnerable but the port city is
encircled by russian forces
nearly a half a million people mostly
russian speakers are trapped
there's no heating electricity water
natural gas connections in other words
there is nothing no household
commodities
a ceasefire was supposed to be in place
here allowing people a chance to find
food or escape if they could but for the
second day
that promise of security was shattered
russia's relentless bombardment
including of civilians trying to flee
prevents people from safely escaping the
hellish conditions that they've created
the hellish conditions are expected to
deteriorate gorham says starvation in
the city will lead to more deaths and
there's no suggestion the bombings will
stop crystal gamson global news
london
prime minister justin trudeau along with
senior ministers were in berlin today
continuing talks with nato allies they
were asked about the attack on that
maternity hospital and president
zielinski's repeated pleas for a no-fly
zone here's what deputy prime minister
christie freeland said
when i look at those pictures
i have to stop looking at them
it is
[Music]
an atrocity what is happening in ukraine
and i think a person
would have to have a heart of stone
to not be moved
and to not be moved by the appeals of
president zielenski at the same time
we need to be
very very thoughtful around escalation
and that's and that's the line that
we're walking
a no-fly zone freeland says would cross
that line abigail beeman is traveling
with the canadian delegation in berlin
the historic brandenburg gate
a visit to a former train platform in
berlin where 50 thousand jews were taken
to ghettos and death camps justin
trudeau reflects on the past while
meeting with allies to try and stop
what's happening in the present
war is once again
raging in the middle of europe for the
first time since 1939 when my country
started
the second world war democracy
is always stronger than authoritarianism
trudeau began his day with a call with
ukraine's president telling volodymir
zalensky canada will send precision
cameras for surveillance drones as part
of a new 50 million dollar equipment
boost while acknowledging getting all
the aid canada has previously promised
across the border into ukraine hasn't
been easy
logistical challenges that are real but
not insurmountable a different challenge
how to get european countries to move
away from russian oil and gas they
depend on passage
germany is interested in canadian
hydrogen as an alternative canada is
interested too but experts say we're
still years away from being in a
position to produce enough at home to
send abroad we do need to just speed up
our hydrogen facilities for production
storage even shipping of hydrogen so
that we can
enter these international low carbon
hydrogen markets as soon as possible
germany meanwhile has suspended
nordstream 2 a major pipeline project
for more russian gas they are bearing
enormous costs and what they are
prepared to do is an indication of what
the west is prepared to do so germany is
the most important country in this whole
dilemma and that is why trudeau is there
another major move by germany reversing
decades of pacifist policy in the wake
of world war ii shipping weapons to
ukraine the country has pledged to
double its defense budget asked several
times about canada's defense spending
the prime minister left the door open
but wouldn't commit
abigail beeman global news berlin
there are growing concerns tonight about
two ukrainian nuclear power plants the
largest facility is occupied by russian
forces who are reported to be holding
employees captive and working them to
exhaustion and power has been cut to the
closed chernobyl nuclear facility mike
armstrong reports on what's at stake and
what nuclear experts are watching for
the international atomic energy agency
says there is no critical impact on
safety right now but that losing power
at the defunct chernobyl plant violates
a fundamental safety precaution
the facility was seized by russian
troops in the first hours of the
invasion now ukraine says power lines to
the facility have been cut by fighting
in the area emergency diesel generators
have kicked in but according to the
ukrainian foreign affairs minister they
can only power the plant for 48 hours in
a tweet he says after that cooling
systems of the storage facility for
spent nuclear fuel will stop making
radiation leaks imminent the iaea says
for now there is enough water in the
cooling reservoirs but it also confirms
its access to sensors at the facility
has been cut this canadian nuclear
expert says he trusts the u.n agency but
he'd like it to be there
they should be allowed
into the facility and all the facilities
in the ukraine
uh so that we do have an expert and
independent voice on these issues and it
seems like that communication has been
cut off which which is disturbing in
itself
now there are also developments of the
zapariza nuclear power plant russia
attacked and seized that facility last
friday the biggest nuclear power plant
in europe ukraine's energy minister is
accusing russian troops of holding the
staff hostage russia propaganda machine
he also claims the staff is being forced
to participate in a video that's being
produced to depict everything as being
fine
the russian foreign ministry meantime
says its troops seize the facilities to
prevent ukrainian nationalists and
terrorists from causing a nuclear
problem
now of the two the zapariza plant is
more modern and less likely to be a
problem in terms of radiation leaks
chernobyl is older but it does have two
containment structures over it the last
one was put in place just six years ago
experts say if there was a problem it
shouldn't be as serious as it would have
been without those containment
structures
it wouldn't spread as widely but it
could be a real problem for staff donna
mike armstrong in la vie ukraine thanks
in the u.s the pentagon says russia has
fired more than 700 missiles at
ukrainian targets in the last two weeks
it says ukraine's ground defenses
including surface-to-air missiles have
helped hold back russian advances and
the u.s has rejected an offer by poland
to transfer its 28 mig fighters to an
american air base in germany so they
could be sent into ukraine the pentagon
spokesperson john kirby says that has
been deemed too high risk
the transfer of combat aircraft right
now could be mistaken
by mr putin and the russians as an
escalatory step should this conflict
escalate uh even further but it's
certainly not going to be good for the
ukrainian people
to have
what is already
a destructive and terrible war get even
more destructive and terrible over two
million people have fled ukraine many to
neighboring nations including moldova a
country declared a state of emergency
and closed its airspace when russia
invaded ukraine and it opened its
borders to refugees moldova a former
soviet republic between ukraine and
romania is home to 2.6 million people
it's not a nato or european union member
though moldova's president has applied
to join the eu 20 years ago
russian-backed separatists took control
of a region called transnistria where
about 1500 russian troops are stationed
and at the easternmost point of moldova
tens of thousands of ukrainians are
flooding across a border crossing into
the country mercedes stephenson is there
we're here on the ukrainian side of the
border so this is actually ukraine and
what you're seeing here is refugees who
are crossing the border they are going
to walk across into moldova
thousands of people are doing this every
day it is bitterly cold it is windy
people are waiting in line for hours
many have walked a long way
there are mostly women and children and
the elderly who are crossing there are
also some men
like the men that you see behind me here
these men are fighting age so usually
they would have to stay behind but these
particular men are looking for political
asylum in moldova so they will be
crossing and hoping that they are
allowed to leave the country but by far
the vast majority of people who we're
seeing here are women with young
children and the elderly very difficult
weight
certainly in the tent behind us there is
food there is hot soup but it is so
difficult for the people that have made
this journey physically emotionally
people we've been talking to who say
bullets narrowly miss them that they
have gone from city to city that is
being bombed
basically dodging their way through
ukraine across roads that are no longer
possible to find their way to this point
they have no idea where they're going to
go after this
there is a quiet strength among these
ukrainians as they wait but the trauma
is etched on their faces you can feel
the anxiety of the life they knew
suddenly interrupted by war
and the urgency of their need to get to
safety as they anticipate a renewed
assault on nearby odessa
mercedes-stevenson global news at the
polanco border crossing in ukraine
a major shift in public health
restrictions coming up when ontario will
drop most of its mass mandates
ontario has become the latest province
to announce a roadmap to end all covet
19 public health restrictions as of
march 21st mass will no longer be
required in the majority of indoor
settings including schools and large
event spaces most isolation requirements
for close contacts are also being
dropped
the lifting of public health and
workplace safety measures and the end of
weekly updates does not signal that
covet 19 has disappeared or that the
pandemic it is over what it means is
that we have come to a place where we
know what we need to do to manage this
virus
mass are still required in high risk
settings like hospitals and public
transit though ontario says the plan is
to lift all mandates on april 27th most
provinces are moving to end mass
mandates alberta and saskatchewan did so
at the beginning of march manitoba nova
scotia new brunswick and newfoundland
have all laid out plans to do so in the
coming days and weeks quebec has begun
phasing them out in schools but hasn't
announced a broader plan bc and pei are
the only provinces not to have announced
their plans
a new report is urging british columbia
to expand its safer drug supply to
prevent more overdose deaths a panel
reviewed more than 6 000 deaths between
august 2017 and july 2021 it found the
primary cause of death was the
increasingly toxic illicit drug supply
the report calls for a safer drug supply
and the development of action plans to
better monitor the crisis drug toxicity
is the leading cause of unnatural death
in british columbia more than 8 700
people have died since the province
declared a public health emergency back
in 2016.
a sad update to a landmark medical case
the first person to receive a heart
transplant from a genetically modified
pig has died american david bennett
passed away two months after his
historic surgery the 57 year old had
terminal heart disease he knew the
procedure was risky a shot in the dark
he called it the hospital did not
provide an exact cause of death but said
he began to deteriorate several days ago
his family thanked them for offering the
experimental transplant they hope it
will help future research
ahead as countries ban russian oil
environmentalists make a push to turn to
greener energy for good
[Music]
canada the u.s and the european union
have committed to reducing or completely
banning the import of russian oil and
gas there is going to be an immediate
need to replace that supply but there's
also pressure to use this moment to push
for a faster transition to green energy
ann gaviola explains
environmental lawyer phil puffin has
been a longtime advocate for a shift
away from car culture as if we needed
another wake-up call the pandemic shift
to remote work and virtual meetings have
some people rethinking daily commutes
and in-person business trips
and now with war in ukraine forcing a
re-evaluation of the world's reliance on
russia he thinks this could be steps
towards a larger shift there's a
confluence of things that are happening
all at once that are going to cause this
change to stick this time
global gas prices have soared above a
hundred dollars a barrel for the first
time since 2014. tuesday on the heels of
the u.s ban on russian oil russia warned
a european ban could lead to an
unpredictable surge and that oil at
three hundred dollars a barrel or more
could be in the making but what this
conflict clearly shows is how dangerous
our dependence on a fossil fuel system
is
analysts say an energy inflation spiral
could squeeze consumers and businesses
and push europe latin america and
eventually north america and china into
a recession
the alberta regional director for the
pembina institute says canada needs to
urgently address what he calls the
climate crisis or we risk falling
further behind countries like china in
the global green shift the amount of
renewable energy production that's
happening there and electric vehicles is
really dramatic
they're becoming a global leader in
these technologies expanding our
reliance on oil and gas increases our
vulnerability it accelerates climate
change the fires and the floods that
were that are already costing us
billions and and displacing millions of
people
worldwide environmentalists say there's
a strong strategic moral and business
case for moving away from fossil fuel
dependence
anne gaviola global news toronto
patience has paid off for a team
searching for one of history's greatest
shipwrecks explorer ernest shackleton's
ship endurance has been found beneath
antarctic ice 106 years after being
crushed by ice an expedition spent weeks
searching the remote location and made
the discovery using state-of-the-art
underwater technology it is 3 000 meters
below the surface upright and according
to the team's director in remarkably
good shape
wood is is as fresh as the day the ship
went down you can see her paint work you
can see the bolts you can see the ship's
name you know endurance curved across
her stern and beneath it the great
five-pointed star
the ship sank in 1915 forcing shackleton
and his 27-man crew to escape on foot
and in small boats it was a 10-month
ordeal to safety he was trying to become
the first to cross antarctica via the
south pole he failed but his journey is
still considered one of the most epic
feats of endurance in antarctic
exploration
endurance is now protected as an
historic site under the antarctic treaty
next how the war in ukraine could make a
global hunger crisis even worse
russia's attack on ukraine is taking
place in a region often called the bread
basket of europe both countries produce
grain that many other countries rely on
especially in the middle east and north
africa redmond shannon explains what the
war if it's prolonged could do to food
supplies for millions of people
ukrainian refugees have fled often
without knowing where their next meal
will come from
inside the country's besieged cities
food is running out a tragic irony in a
part of the world long known as the
bread basket of europe ukraine and
russia are huge producers and exporters
of grains and oil seeds but many
ukrainian farmers have left the fields
to fight and black sea ports are closed
right now knowing how much black sea
actually matters in the scale of the
international grain export it's it's
going to be very very and very bad the
war has strangled supply with the price
of wheat and sunflower seeds breaking
records about 80 percent of sunflower
oil
comes from these two countries
so
the the impact of this crisis is
worldwide this is a disaster for
struggling countries close to ukraine
lebanon where the economy is already in
tatters gets most of its wheat from
there war-torn yemen where hunger is
already a huge problem relies heavily on
affordable grain imports the ripple
effects could soon be felt even more
strongly according to this ukrainian
trade expert it's not just some local
ukrainian russian war and if you don't
have another refugee crisis from those
areas which which will be under fed
this is something that the world needs
to do we need the way of ending this the
world food programme says the war
compounds the effect of covet 19 climate
change and other conflicts it says 44
million people are already on the edge
of famine and that could rise further
unless it gets more funds better still
would be an end to this and other wars
redmond shannon global news london
that is global national for this
wednesday i'm donna friesen in ukraine's
capital city today an orchestra
assembled for an open-air concert we
leave you tonight with some of their
music
the kiev classical symphony orchestra
set up in medan square and among the
songs they played was ukraine's national
anthem the lyrics translated to english
say the glory and freedom of ukraine has
not yet perished our enemies will vanish
like dew in the sun
thanks for watching hope to see you here
again tomorrow
[Music]
so
you